travis where's his family  they're calling on the wild mop brought  together by one man  baywater  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  here's the kid that's the kid you pulled  out of the creek  you're going to kill my uncle i see that  depends on you  if we're gonna work together you should  learn to shoot just stay calm  gently squeeze the trigger  then you've got the high ground you  control everything  [Music]  see this crown  you stand for justice absolutely then  you give us  justice for the man who killed my family  you know our civilizations built  something bad men  doing bad things bad men like me and you  what are you doing you lied say it  whatever made you think you could change  who you are  you